pending four Sundays this month taking a
look at leaders of American media we're
joined from Madison Wisconsin by James
Bachman who's the professor of Henry are
loose and the rise of the American media
good morning thanks for being with us
good morning who was Henry Luce well
Henry Luce was the child of American
missionaries in China who with his best
friend in college Britt hadn't found a
time magazine he went on to found
Fortune magazine Sports Illustrated Life
magazine the march of time newsreel
really perhaps the most important
periodical publisher in American
American history and why did you decide
to write a book about him well I felt
that in our understanding of American
journalism particularly in the 20th
century there was a there was a whole
there was something we didn't understand
I think if you look at what happened to
American journalism between 1900 and
1960 or 1970 the biggest difference is
how much more analytical how much more
interpretive American journalism became
how much more likely reporters were to
synthesize information and explain it
for us I think that's the that's the
most powerful way I think of
understanding what happened American
journalism in the last century and I
think Henry Luce goes a long way toward
explaining that change let me begin
where you start in your book in
describing him and what he represented
in the late 1930s you say he was
America's single most powerful and
innovative mass communicator
Henry Robinson Luce had started
distinctive and popular magazines taken
together these publications provided a
more gripping and coherent view of the
world than was to be found in similar
periodicals and daily newspapers up
until then how so well I think the
difference is one thing I did when I was
working on the book is that is that I
looked at American newspapers in the
1930s I looked at competing magazines in
the 1930s and what struck you was that
that other publications tended to give
you a mass of facts
whereas luces magazine especially time
and lie
I've tried two more I think than most to
weave them into a coherent whole to try
to explain what had happened the
previous week and that's what made loose
very different but also what caused
loose I think to anticipate the
direction of American journalism not
just in print but in broadcast as well
where where so much information was was
repackaged reformulated so that it made
sense and this again goes to the early
part of the book but he spent a lot of
time in China as he was growing up why
well his parents were missionaries in
China
his father was it was a Presbyterian
minister and North China Luce was
actually born in China and you know the
the he and his his siblings were raised
in a compound in North China and I
believe Luce was about 14 when he
actually left China to come to school in
the United States did that affect his
thinking of the United States in the
world it did very much for a couple of
reasons one is this is a moment the
beginning of the 20th century
when the United States is feeling its
oats is feeling it's it's sense that we
are a world power we are the seventh
power whatever the number was at that at
that time and yet one thing loose had to
deal with as many Americans did living
overseas at the time was the haughtiness
of the great of Great Britain of the
British people that they would deal with
loose went to a British school and che
foo what was then Shifu China and was
subject to their humiliations the Brits
looked down on us as you know the the
Colonials and so forth and it really
infuriated him and it made him more
nationalistic it's it's often been said
that missionary children were more
nationalistic than Americans living you
know back home in Nebraska or Alabama
because of the evaluations they put up
with put up with overseas what led to
the start of Time magazine and who
funded the operation well a couple of
things they had the idea hadn't and
loose going back to prep school actually
if you look at their prep school new
paper which I did what you'll see is
they they were convinced that that there
was too much news in the newspaper that
that what was needed was a new kind of
newspaper that was their original idea
by the way but a new type of news
publication that organized information
in a way that the busy young man and
loosen hadn't imagine themselves as
their as their reader would be able to
read it and know what they needed to
know in in the early 1920s and that was
that was I think that the major
incentive there as far as the funding
there was a marvelous advantage to going
to Yale or Harvard in the early 1920s
and that was it connected you to a lot
of families of great wealth
although Lewis and Hatton's families
weren't particularly well-to-do
certainly not losses they did have
access through their clubs and so forth
at Yale to some very wealthy families
and they they hit those families up for
contributions to start the magazine and
when Time magazine was first launched
how many people read it and how is it
distributed I don't have those numbers
in front of me was the circulation was
was fairly modest initially but it was
it was a money-making proposition within
a few years I mean they were breaking
even
what has resulted from Time magazine
what is the The Time Inc how many
companies now make up the corporation
quite a few of course Time Inc merged
with with Warner Communications in 1990
it bought Turner Broadcasting Turner's
holdings in the mid-1990s and then that
fish was eaten up by AOL in in 2001 so
there's been it's it's now really is a
vast empire of many different media uh
there's another photograph of Henry Luce
and his wife Claire booth this is from
their honeymoon in Cuba back in the mid
1930s who was Clara booth and how did
the two meet she was an extraordinary
woman who met loose in in the mid-1930s
Luce was was married and had had several
children so those sons Luce was
absolutely captivated by her she was a
very striking woman her a beautiful
woman a very smart woman and Luce was
was absolutely I think and madly in love
with her and divorced his first wife and
and married Claire I believe in 1936
they they will remain married for the
remainder of Lucy's life she went on to
a very interesting career she had been a
playwright an actress stage actress she
was also elected to Congress from
Connecticut and actually sought the
Republican nomination for the US Senate
and lost it to Prescott Bush the
president's grandfather our phone lines
are open is we continue our look yet
leaders in American media
2:02 585 3883 is our line for
international viewers for the rest of
you to 0 to 585 3880 for Republicans to
0 to 585 38 81 for Democrats and if
you're a member of a third party to zero
to five eight five three eight eight to
our guest is James
joining us from Madison Wisconsin what
are you doing these days well I teach
the history of journalism and
occasionally the history of the United
States here at the uw-madison and have
since 1979 and I'm working on another
book a history of television in the
1950s what kind of relationship did mr.
Luce have with presidents of his time
very checkered I think up until the
election of Dwight Eisenhower in 1952
Luce didn't really begin to know
presidents begin to be taken seriously
as a journalistic force until the late
1930s early 1940s although he was
affecting journalism a journalist's were
reading time and thought it was very
smart and and and worth imitating Truman
excuse me Luce new came to know
Roosevelt and Truman didn't get along
with either one of them he felt FDR
patronized and Roosevelt would also call
him Henry when everyone who knew him
called him Harry that sort of thing
Eisenhower's election a change the the
relationship Luce had more access his
wife was actually named ambassador to
Italy by a by President Eisenhower and
Luce had fairly steady access of ready
access I should say to presidents
Kennedy and Johnson one of the things
mr. Bachmann that we were able to come
up with is a conversation between mr.
Luce and President Lyndon Johnson this
courtesy of the Johnson tapes at the
library in Texas about 7580 down here
and it's just as warm and pretty as it
can be did you have a good Christmas and
I wish you would any day she's around
just tell her I'll be waiting with open
arms and you give her a big hug for me
I'm sorry I interrupt your lunch I just
wanted I just wanted to visit with you
and tell you what are you coming back
east why don't you come down to see me
in next there - err - get up there I
want you to take my tax bill pass it
from I've got tax bill on civil rights
and I've got to get them both on before
they start playing too much politics and
then we can have a lot of time to have
fun in the campaign if we'll get these
things behind what I'm trying to do I'm
trying to get a budget down a hundred
billion and take enough out of these
archaic establishments to give a little
bit on our social consciousness little
poverty stuff and a little full the
Appalachia area of West Virginia and
Kentucky and Pennsylvania and I think
come on worked it out where I can get
not too far away from what it was last
year we move made we made some progress
on but I just got to get my tax bill
passed and I won't I want you to give me
some help now see you 18th 20th 21st did
get some sunshine for me take some of
that sunshine for me I've got to go back
to the coal mines on
I'll be thinking of you out there in
Arizona James Popham in that
conversation from 1964 and one of the
photographs in your book from September
1965 with mr. Luce and mr. Johnson what
do you learn from that one thing I'm
noticing is Lucis machine gun delivery
he had a speech impediment as a child
that was was was pretty serious and I'm
struck by how quickly he spoke that's a
that's a small thing of course what
you're also seeing is what was called at
the time the Johnson treatment in which
Lyndon Johnson would call journalists
politicians members of Congress and work
him over flattering that sort of thing
and noticing that he's clearly
cultivating Lucis favor regarding the
tax bill and and a civil rights bill
James Bachman is the author of Henry are
loose and the rise of the American media
let's bring in our calls and also remind
you that the numbers will be on your
screen our lines are open Fredericksburg
Virginia Republican line good morning
yeah good morning gentlemen
I just have very very quick questions
first question is who do I attribute my
demise of my stock is it Warner Time or
AOL the second question is the mr. Luce
it would he would he
okay the Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
Issue wow that's a good question
I think yes we have the diaries of one
of Lucis key editors that I looked at
spent some time reading I think loose
would have would have condoned it I'm
not sure it would have promoted it or
been quite as enthusiastic about it as
as si has been but if you look at the
diary of the editor who put the first
issues of life together it's pretty
clear that a lot that Luce liked having
attractive women of featured in Life
magazine and if you look at Life
magazine that the caller may remember
Life magazine you could always count on
attractive women young women being
featured in the publication as the AOL
stock I will say nothing except that I
was very suspicious of the merger and at
the time but not very many people sought
my counsel on that I'm gonna go through
and this is a list that is far too long
and we would have time to go through
every publication that is owned by Time
Inc but among them including Time
magazine Entertainment Weekly InStyle
Sports Illustrated for kids health
magazine ski magazine this old house
cycle sport prediction Rugby World
family circle home and gardens Country
Life Golf Magazine time Canada time
South Pacific popular science people
money Sports Illustrated fortune just to
name a few
right well I'm I'm more interested in
the in the top you know the flagship
publications I'm more interested myself
not in how many publications time makes
although those smaller ones that the set
you've read have made made them a lot of
money and for instance I believe in
style entertainment we've done quite
well by them but I'm more interested in
in time and si and fortune as magazines
that I think have more influence I think
effect journalism effect opinion leaders
and that sort of thing than I am and
some of those others but you're right
it's a it's a long string it's a it's a
quite a roster you have a account for
all of this do you know how much I'm
publications time puts out on a regular
basis again I don't have a count I'm
more intrigued by how many people
actually read or see the publication and
it intrigues me that Time magazine's
circulation has been fairly flat for the
last 20 or 30 years it really hasn't
grown I find that curious because it did
grow substantially remarkably incredibly
in the thirties forties and fifties next
call Aptos California good morning
Democrats line good morning thank you
very much for taking my call and before
I before I make a couple statements I
just like to say that I I am a Democrat
in case anyone anyone wonders because I
know that in keeping with your policy I
may not sound like one but I am one now
registered Democrat I haven't voted that
in quite some time I'm curious about the
I'm curious about the name of the book
the rise of the news media quite frankly
I think that that that at the time that
they started interpreting the news for
us it was the beginning of the fall of
the news media and I think we're seeing
the we're seeing the final death throes
of of Time magazine Newsweek Network
News all of those all of those the
Talking Heads on on Sundays all of those
news news companies and and and programs
that try to tell us how to how the news
should be interpreted I think that's
that's the rise of Time magazine in in
in the earlier years was of course
because America was much more naive in
our way of thinking we actually believed
these people were expressing the best
things for us quite frankly they were
not they were very much they were very
much involved in their own way of
thinking and what benefited them and not
necessarily in providing news I think
now today and thank goodness it's the
truth
America is much more sophisticated a
clear across the land and we're going to
see the collapse of I know that I
cancelled my
subscriptions of Time and Newsweek 5 to
10 years ago when they kept insisting
that they did not have a liberal bent I
mean that's almost laughable well let me
try that I think that we have to
remember when time started a great
influence on Hadden and Luce was walter
Lippmann Lippmann had been arguing and
and it's an argument that still holds
that the world had become a complex
place and that we needed some kind of
synthesis of information the idea of the
AMA competent citizen that any of us
could acquire all the information we
needed to know was impossible however
much and I share some of the caller's
fatigue with with the you know and anger
and I think I felt I have felt as a
consumer of news over a reporter sort of
telling me what just happened when
particularly if I'm there I feel that
well maybe certain things were left out
on the other hand I don't think loose
and hadn't were too off the mark when
they said people are busy and we need
somebody in this case the writers at
time and life to to tell us what
happened or what we need to know that's
been going on in Europe or Africa or
Asia and by the way I think many of the
people who worked for Harry Luce most of
them were very purposeful men and women
they were they were they tried to do a
very good job and I'm not sure I share
the all of the all of the caller's
cynicism about their motives Luce
reconsidered this is a quote than the
book the very structure of a news story
rather than organized facts by their
significance in the manner of The
Associated Press
Luce and Hayden would arranged them as
true stories with a beginning middle and
end you go on to write mr. Baughman that
the news would be written and organized
differently a week's events would be
compartmentalized into regular
departments and summarized into entries
of no more than 400 words 7 inches of
type why was that significant
they wanted you to be able to read Time
magazine in a half an hour and know what
what you needed to know and to be to be
sufficiently informed and their idea was
their conceit was it was the conceit of
young men who didn't know what they
didn't know was that they could take an
issue such as in the early 20s the the
troubles in Ireland and they could they
could take every article in the New York
Times and the New York world and other
other publications and synthesize it and
tell you in 400 words what happened but
not only do that because other
publications were doing that and had
been doing that for for some time but
that they would structure it in a way
that was engaging that was interesting
that might start with a little story
there was an entry on Germany in the in
the 1930s that begin in 1920s excuse me
that began with President Hindenburg's
birthday party featuring his
granddaughter's it was quite charming
but then went on to make a major point
what was going on in Germany and the
idea was to engage the reader at the
same time tell the reader this is what's
happened that you really need to know
and that was different that was a the
language was different though the words
they would in some cases invent words or
popularized words to grab people and one
other point from your early in the book
about this style of Time magazine you're
right that time was a collective
Enterprise compared to a newspaper which
might have one reporter composed and one
or more editors review the copy time had
three or more individuals engaged in
writing most entries initially none
actually witnessed events only in the
early 1930s did time begin to do some
reporting one of the most one of the
best written pieces I ran across in
times first decade was an account of
President Coolidge his funeral
January 1933 died in Vermont and of
course the old Coolidge joke is how did
they know he was dead but but in any
case that story was a I believe was
written in New York I read
diary of the man who wrote that story
and I don't think he went up to Plymouth
Vermont to write it and yet if you read
that story all the detail that's in it
about the weather about the roads and so
forth pulled from other accounts but
recast reconfigure it in a way that's
quite masterful and it's quite moving
it's it's I think I think if I were to
do my top 10 lists of anything ever
written in Time magazine the death of
Coolidge would be there Alexandria
Virginia on the Republican line you're
next
yes hello I have just a couple quick
questions first do you think there is
anyone in modern media and business that
is kind of the equivalent of a loose
someone who is not only kind of on the
revolutionary edge of maybe a new style
of journalism but also holds the same
political influence and financial
influence that that loose obviously had
I don't think so I think that I might
have said I might have offered some
names of years ago but I don't think
there is anyone on the horizon today any
single individual someone might say
Murdock Ted Turner might have been that
person 10 years ago I don't think there
is anyone there's a difference is that
loose created an empire but he also
clearly wanted to influence this country
and its culture and I don't think
today's mass media managers care about
those second goals I think their main
concern is is running their companies
and expanding their companies that's
what they care about it's it's not I'm
not saying they're lacking and
patriotism or anything like that but I
don't think that I mean loose loose was
a missionary son it was like a lot of
mass communicators like the advertising
agent Bruce Barton he was a minister's
son he there was a I think there was an
element I don't want to say of guilt of
his having gone into business but there
was a sense that I shouldn't just be
making money did he come from money
no absolutely not he did have a did have
a sugar mama sugar of
benefactress Nettie mcCormick of the
mccormick family of Reaper fortune in
Chicago helped the Lucis help subsidize
the Lucis Enterprise and shine and help
pay for losses education and help help
fund Time Magazine's start sale Paulo
Brazil is our next caller good morning
to you good morning folks my question is
a Time magazine and also all their
American magazines are sold overseas
including Brazil and many other
countries but they are read by in you
know in politicians and important people
I would like mr. James moment to talk
about how does that relate to American
international policy and even American
journalists how did they relate to that
question thank you an excellent question
it's one that I sort of skated around in
my book Time magazine one of one of the
reasons Luce was respected and even
feared by people like John Kennedy was
Kennedy's conviction that Time magazine
was read and read closely by elites
political and other elites in overseas I
think that it's influenced all beings to
know if the caller feels this way I
think Time magazine has much less
influence overseas now than it did 40
years ago because of the explosion of
cable news services overseas but but
regardless of that you you do have that
that influence still even today I
suspect I would say as an aside that one
of the more embarrassing aspects one of
the one of the least attractive thing is
to look at it when you go back and read
as I invite you to do Time magazine in
the in the 30s 40s and 50s is how
patronizing and condescending time was
towards Latin America or South America
that was not it's not pleasant to read
now very very dismissive and it cost
Claire Luce her being ambassador to
Brazil under Dwight Eisenhower in case
you've just joined us we are taking a
closer look at Henry our loose
is the founder of Time magazine and Time
Inc one of a series of American leaders
that were focusing on last week we took
a look at the life and times of William
Randolph Hearst next week by the way on
the 30th anniversary of the Watergate
break-in we will shift our attention to
the impact that Watergate had here in
Washington on a number of areas
including journalism and then we'll
resume our series when we look at the
CBS founder William Paley and wrap
things up with a look at Ted Turner
James Bachman is joining us from Madison
Wisconsin he is a professor he's also
the author of Henry our loose and the
rise of the American media our next call
is from El Centro California good
morning good morning not I have a
question in your research did you and
come across the name of Homer Lee who
was an acquaintance of Clare Boothe Luce
yes
yes I read a book by him about 30 years
ago and it was written in the 20s or
maybe in the late teens predicting it's
a struggle and conflict between the u.s.
and Japan and me up to such things there
was that book sir the valour of
ignorance yes it is yeah that's a
predicting a war within the Pacific I
think he had a scenario where they were
gonna might invade Oregon and think
Japanese might invade Oregon and things
like that and what was interesting about
that it was was a time when it was
written and the forward in the book was
written by Clara there was yeah it was
interesting but an interesting figure
I'm I'm not remembering the details on
him but it was there were several books
published at the time that forecast a
Pacific War Alize was the most I think
the most gripping because he actually
had a series of invasion scenarios
involving the West Coast United States
being a middle Westerner I wasn't as
alarmed I suppose is somewhere you
touched on these two individuals earlier
but the relationship between Harry or
Henry Luce and it's interchangeable
isn't it between Henry and Harry he
really preferred being called Harry I
was struck by that Johnson tape you
played that that Linden called him Henry
FDR did that he really preferred Harry
but the relationship between Henry are
loose and Clare Boothe Luce that's
that's for another author I mean that's
something
I talked about in a sense but I didn't
get into in great detail they were very
much in love initially and I think they
always I believe they always respected
each other immensely but the marriage
wasn't as shall we say as stable as it
as it one might have hoped over the 30
years that they were Wed they were very
strong personalities very difficult very
prickly personalities in their own way
and they weren't faithful to each other
and but but still remain married and I
think in many ways very much in love
Richmond Michigan Democrats line good
morning Marty gentlemen
first of all make our tech repair a
quick remark in 1953 I was a young naval
officer stationed aboard a huge
communication ship in Maples Bay the big
ships used to come in and dock veteran
of the Andrea Doria pulls up one day
happens to be at the gangplank and this
woman comes he's shoving the gangplank
general was a Clare Boothe Luce and I
remember looking at arising her faces
look close by was a limousine I walk by
the limousine and sitting in the
limousine was mr. loose and she handed
him a brown bag I mean I remember seeing
him opening up there was a sandwich a
sandwich she brought him his son which
in a brown bag eyes she bailed him and
walked off now you just did a story of a
Hurst and I'm thinking a murder and how
roger ailes just be hired by him Aled
hires all these people ales you get on
your program has a picture of a George
Bush in the background and his
connection with Rush Limbaugh and then
you mentioned Prescott Bush journalists
somebody recalled in a few months a few
weeks ago and said Dulles
rather a letter from Dulles to press
Bush who was a banker on Wall Street now
I'm talking about when you beat my
family than you be I have friends who
became very wealthy their political
philosophy changes
and I slip my trove of thought here but
I believe that this political political
philosophy oh yeah Murdoch Rupert
Murdoch a magic and then I read stories
of him entertaining our legislators done
now you're getting the campaign finance
reform I I truly believe that I hope
that we have a nonpartisan type of type
of people who write stories for our pay
our American people but I guess my
question my well that final question is
that anything and missin his wife does
she write any memoirs and she did she
telegraph anything in her writings in
her books of her political philosophy of
I'm gonna stop you there and we'll get a
response she was she did write a lot she
never wrote a memoir there have been
there have been several biographies of
Claire loose and and a long appreciative
essay about her by Wilfred she'd she
wrote a great deal in her in her own
lifetime and became politically much
more conservative than Henry was Henry
Luce was always I think a moderate
moderate conservative in his politics
compared to Claire Claire was for
instance an active supporter of Barry
Goldwater in 1964 and Harry wouldn't
wouldn't have it although he liked
Goldwater personally he would not allow
his publications to endorse Goldwater
whom he felt was just too conservative
but the Clair wrote quite a bit I tried
to meet with her when I was I was
working on the book but at this point it
was toward the end of the line and and
she wasn't talking to strangers when did
she pass away I want to say in the
nineties I am
1988 something like that as late 80s
early early nineties our phone lines are
open also you can email us at journal @
c-span org Silver Spring Maryland
Republican line your next good morning
good morning I want to add on to what a
caller said few calls back about the
mainstream media being biased over the
years I just got sick and tired of
hearing traditional values being trashed
whenever there were women issues they
always went to the national organization
of women you never heard anything from
Concerned Women of America
talk radio I totally listen to talk
radio
Rush Limbaugh Michael Savage in
particular I just had it with the
alphabet channels and I'm sick and tired
of them being the mouthpiece of the
Liberals in this country that's the big
difference between the mass media today
and the mass media of 30 or 40 years ago
I recall growing up in Ohio in the late
60s and you didn't have those choices
you were stuck with with with the
networks you did wait for Time magazine
if you were middle class houses growing
up middle class home as I was he waited
for time or Newsweek to arrive and and
so forth you didn't have the choices
that you have now so the kind of
frustration that the caller is
manifesting at least can be can be you
know can be you know can be dealt with
through those alternative media which
did not exist several decades ago James
Bachman is joining us from Madison
Wisconsin where he teaches at the
University of Wisconsin Madison
professor of journalism he's also the
author of a book on Henry Arliss
attended Harvard graduated from Columbia
where he earned his doctorate degree go
back later in your book you talk about
Henry Luce in the 1950s and mentioned
that he had wanted to run for the
Republican nomination from the for the
US Senate from Connecticut in 1950 or
reluctantly letting friends talk him out
of making the race he was surrendering
his last chance for elective office how
interested was he
in politics for himself personally
there's a point in his life where I
really date it to 1937-38 when when his
magazines have stabilized and in fact
are doing quite well there's a point
lose his life where he he he he wants to
become a public man he really would like
to enter public life but the opportunity
never quite presents itself he thought
of you know he might end up the
Secretary of State if if a certain
Republican were elected he did think of
running for the Senate in Connecticut
people who knew loose including ones who
liked him have said they couldn't quite
imagine him running for public office
because he had a very difficult manner
very abrupt you sort of heard that
machine gun delivery in the in the tape
from the Johnson library but the
political public service obligations
were there and and I and in some ways I
think were kind of neat and it was kind
of it was kind of revealing that here
was someone who wasn't again unlike
today's mass media moguls here was
someone who had aspired as something
beyond his publishing Empire Vernon
Virginia good morning on our line for
independence good morning I've got a
question I'll get to in a second but
first I'd like to respond to that caller
who obviously listens to Rush Limbaugh
and right-wing radio and Christian radio
and if he thinks that that's a balance
he is sadly mistaken I have to listen to
the only two really liberal broadcasters
they're all on the internet because they
are banned from the Airways Mike Malloy
and Peter worthy so this idea that the
radio presents a balanced view is
absolutely ludicrous now to my question
how did the call between Luce and
President Johnson can you please go into
the details of how Luce would use that
call and and and use his friendship with
the President to run with this agenda
thank you I I don't know I don't know
how he would use it I think that was
more a case of Johnson trying to use
and vice-versa loose was I may be wrong
about this loose was rarely rarely
handed scoops from from leading
newsmakers I think that that the way to
regard that phone call is Johnson is
trying to persuade Luce to persuade his
lieutenant Headley Donovan very great
editor-in-chief of Time Inc to present
Johnson's tax and civil rights bill and
in a more positive light I don't I don't
think that that Luce was looking for a
scoop there in that regard Crystal River
Florida Democrats line for James Bachman
good morning good morning
mr. belman and thank you for taking my
call I have been a student of philosophy
for the past thirty years and in
particular I have focused on the
relationship of cause and effect on a
national scale it strikes me that the
u.s. is entering into a period of major
trouble which is of course evidenced to
some degree by the situation of 9/11 and
the tragedies that were caused I wonder
about your opinion regarding the fact
that our media may not be focusing on
the major issues that are facing our
nation at this time it seems that it's
focusing on a thousand small issues in
particular issues that might symbolize
our difficulties such as how our
children are being harmed in this
country now in many different ways how
we seem to have lost the drug wars and
perhaps most symbolically how we seem to
be losing our morals our ethics and and
perhaps even our basic goodness that
made this nation great thanks for the
call comment
I'm not sure I that I can respond to
that question I was I was anticipating
he was gonna he was gonna ask me
something else so I'm gonna have to pass
on that when did the first edition of
Time magazine roll off the presses March
was late February early March 1923 and
where did the name time come from they
wanted it well they thought of they
thought of dime they thought of fact
they had a couple of ideas the idea was
time would if you in effect if you
invested the time and reading it you
would come away a well informed a man
and by the way they did put it that way
they said man they targeted men
originally and didn't realize how many
women were reading the magazine was
there anything comparable to Time
magazine at that time there was it was
called the literary digest which was a
immensely popular magazine in fact
loosin hadn't were assured by some of
their potential investors that time
would never take off because the
literary digest was so popular the
literary die just came out once a week
and did some of what time did it
presented stories but quoted heavily
from newspapers didn't have a point of
view which time affected to possess so
you'd be reading it would be would be
more like a clipping almost a clipping
service compared to time next called
berkeley california good morning yes i
the last caller touched upon drugs and
it's my recollection that both of the
losses were involved with the LSD at
some time in their careers and how do
you know that what because i recall
while reading about it in time it was
true no it's true it was I mean it was
and it's it's in several of the of the
the treatments of loose and and and and
Claire Luce he they both experiment with
LSD was very early on when the the
effects of the drug were not known it
was it was sort of a designer drug and
they were both curious I mean they were
both journalists and thought they'd try
it
loose if I recall the story correctly it
is not I don't it may be in my book but
I know it's it's it's in some of the
treatments loose I think at one point
claimed he had spoken to God as a
consequence of taking the LSD he lived
on a golf course and and it was a good
sight to sort of I guess if you were
going to meet God to take it late it
late in the in in the afternoon or
something like that
Middletown New Jersey Republican line
good morning hello hello Mitch
to speak go ahead caller okay I'm
calling because about the media I'm a
little nervous
several years ago we me and a group of
people found the need to bring some
media information to the public because
we saw repeatedly in the paper that a
certain side of an issue was never being
covered it was an abstinence bill that
was being pushed through the through the
legislation by it was it was introduced
by Miriam Greco
Assemblywoman in New Jersey and we
brought a speaker named Richard Smith
and with the help of Assemblyman mr.
rasulina we were able to get the use of
the Brookdale College and the speaker
mr. Richard Smith was speaking on
condoms because he felt they were
actually dangerous and the media never
ever covered anything about the opposite
side of the bill and it was new
information and it was information that
was never heard in the paper and so we
wanted to bring him so that and we
invited the newspapers to come and cover
it so that the public would get another
side of the view and when he came and he
spoke he he gave all different
information and aspects of the issue and
when the newspaper printed it they
printed nothing they just put all the
same old information and again and I had
called the the Education Department to
invite them and they seemed to feel that
somehow they got a hold of the media and
they
Quelch the story and I believe the media
does do this
generally speaking James boffin what's
your assessment of that that view I
think this is one of the lies about not
what the other callers I'm glad the
caller raised this issue because one of
the lies about the information age is
how inform we are and we forget that
things like this still don't get covered
daily newspapers in particular many of
them have cut back on their reporting
resources in favor of because it can
save money and earn more money and I
think what what there may be two things
operating here and again I I don't know
the specifics so I trust that the the
caller will understand that one is the
newspaper simply may not have the
resources to cover this thing and the
other possibility which I think the
caller suspects is that there is a
cultural bias against that position on
on on sexual relations and teens and so
forth that causes the newspaper now not
not to do it but what I would would urge
all of the the viewers to consider who
get mad at newspapers or TV stations for
not covering something is rather than
think that it's ideology it's it may
well be bookkeeping that the TV station
can't afford to send a crew to the
speech because they they only have one
or two crews and and they've spent all
that money on their set Hollywood
Florida Democrats line good morning good
morning actually a part of the question
I was going to ask you is what the
gentlemen did before I was going to ask
I seem to see when they have these
reporting interviews with the military
and State Department and Rumsfeld and
those people they ask like questions
like from a previous scripted novel
there's no investigative reporting going
on today yeah thing is part of what
statement you give a few moments ago and
frankly it's a little frightening
because without an investigative
reporting the Sunshine Law would be
obsolete and I've been completely black
and
you can get away with anything and God
help us then thank you
well actually I think what we call
investigative or enterprise reporting is
still taking place but it's it's not I
think some newspapers have cut back one
of the biggest changes in Time magazine
and Newsweek in the past 30 years and I
invite you to go to your library and
look at Newsweek or time thirty years
ago I did that for an essay I wrote a
couple years ago is there is more
Enterprise reporting now but more
investigative reporting than there used
to be much more our larger daily
newspapers still invest heavily in and
if if fitfully an investigative
reporting but across the board I'm not
sure it's it's there with the same same
resolutions there should be after the
publication of Time magazine what came
that next was it fortune fortune fortune
magazine was excuse me was 1930 and I
think by the way fortune magazine in its
first six years was the greatest
American magazine ever published it was
followed in 1936 by Life magazine which
was the most popular publication loose
ever ever oversaw and the Sports
Illustrated came in 1954 and that was
the last of the major publications loose
over some People magazine came several
years after about seven years after
Lucis death and why are you so high on
Fortune magazine during its first five
or six years I think it was it was
gloriously written it was sort of the
opposite it was it was times of con it
was it was it very much designed to be
in contrast to time the essays were
longer some cases ten thousand words it
was gorgeously put together in terms of
illustrations the paper was was
beautiful the illustrations the artwork
was extraordinary and Luce assembled a
stable of writers many of them by the
way knew nothing about business to to
write some some quite marvelous pieces
and I know my own students are quite
sick of me telling them that they should
looking at fortune during that period it
was a it was one of those moments in the
life of a periodical when everything
clicked Moss Point Mississippi
independent line good morning for James
Hoffman from the University of Wisconsin
at Madison good morning good morning mr.
Boozman I'm gonna talk Big Bertha for
Traverse with you more about the
television the obvious and printed media
that this release was involved with but
my question to you is mr. Lewis was
obviously obviously understood the value
of the media and this relationship to
politics and my question is as we see
the need for campaign finance reform and
things of this nature the major one of
the major campaign finance expenses is
obviously advertising and media access
and I wanted to know what your thoughts
would be or have you run into this and
your research of how mr. Lewis and his
access and the media ran together
what would the thoughts be on on
allowing public television which is a
tax funded entity to some degree already
to provide free access to the media or
pretty much all potential candidates
which would eliminate the need for this
great war chest to fight the the media
battle and the advertisement battle
candidates and and wouldn't that allow
access more access to the public by
candidates and also more access to the
candidates by the public and you know
maybe free up a greater amount of time
so that instead of getting $50,000
30-second sound bites from a candidate
we could get some some valuable
information from the candidate in an
extended an extended contact on honor
honor on a media outlet that it's
already paid for by the voters anyway
and if I could mr. Baughman just to tag
onto that caller's point in answering
his issues how do you think he would
view the media today I think he'd be I
think he'd be excited and appalled
I think he'd be fascinated about what
the Internet can do what what websites
can do I think he'd be very disappointed
in the trivial agenda that seems to it
seems to dominate so many publications I
think he'd be very distinct in that
scent to be disappointed I'd be I'm not
sure how we would rely react to the
redesign of Time magazine and and
whether he'd be pleased or not with that
I think he'd be a little disappointed in
us the readers the citizens I think
Americans take news less seriously even
after 9/11 then we did a generation ago
and I think Luce would be a little you'd
raise those eyebrows he had wondering
why you know why are we more interested
in more serious issues dollars point
about campaign finance and the amount of
money spent on advertising I I have
worked on that issue a bit and and and
and studied it a bit but that's a that's
another show it's not something I feel I
can talk about the problem with duck if
I may put it this crudely with dumping
all the politicians on public stations
is that people would wouldn't watch them
they would they would still I think
escape to other channels most most
people advance Missouri Republican line
good morning good morning did you
consider left or Annenberg for this
media series and mr. Bachmann would you
please comment on him very interesting
character character perhaps is unfair
but a very interesting figure I wouldn't
consider him for this series in the
sense that although he had some
influence and made an extraordinary
investment in buying TV Guide and I
believe 1953 you're starting it I don't
think he said nearly the impact on
journalism that that Lou said that
Hearst had and some of the other other
figures were talking about he's still a
great story it's Tannenberg family is a
great story and to to that caller and
others who are interested in giving us
some ideas our email address is journal
at c-span org and we welcome
any of your comments and suggestions
will get a call from Hoboken New Jersey
on the Democrats line good morning hi
good morning it's nice to be speaking
with you folks I really admire c-span in
general and quality of guests that you
get are really extraordinary
I was wondering how this gentleman would
perceive let's just say that how would
you say that the media's perspective and
to what extent is it inhibited in its
reporting by its relationship to its
advertisers and politicians and politics
and the government in general okay
as far as advertisers and concerned I
don't think that that's that's an issue
at timing publications at least the
larger ones I hope I'm not being naive
in that I think lay observers of the of
the press often assume that advertisers
have this kind of influence I don't
think that that occurs now there have
been some very unpleasant episodes
involving advertisers and other
magazines unhappy with content and so
forth but and I know and luces lifetime
it was not an issue in fact Luce was
amused when when it was charged that he
was subject to that kind of influence as
far as politicians are concerned I think
there two forms of biases can operate
one is a source bias that your access to
a source can affect how you treat that
source and this includes the publication
like Sports Illustrated but 9/11 has in
some ways rewritten reconfigured the
relationship of the press to those in
power
I think the reporters have shown a much
greater willingness to believe the
government than was evident before
September 11th do you know I'm sure I've
answered that question but I you know
gave it a shot do you know on average
how many people read Time magazine
weekly I do not I had that and I
apologize for that that as I say the
circulation has been has been somewhat
flat
since the early 70s it's still a very
profitable magazine and you know doesn't
just quite well for for the company
Minneapolis Republican line good morning
good morning we're calling here with
Philip Luce and William Lowe's Trev and
our question is do you remember Earl
David Lewis he was a brigadier general
in the First World War and some of the
relatives had commented on some of the
time that they had spent together and
just wondered if you knew anything
comments on that line no I you you've
stumped me on that and I was at Lee
family from Scranton you know what
Minneapolis because Lucis family was no
I better I better back off on that the
that connection is not clear to me and
James Bachman before we let you go just
quickly go through the chronology of his
life when he came up with Time magazine
and when he died Time magazine was
started in as I say in in in in March of
1923 series of publications we've talked
about including Sports Illustrated 1954
loose will step down as editor-in-chief
which made him the sort of the
Supervisory or sort of supreme editorial
authority at Time Inc in 1964 he will
die
three years later in Phoenix February of
1967 and how did he pass away heart
attack and he'd been had been had had
some heart troubles going back to the
50s
James Bachman who is a professor and
author of Henry R loose and the rise of
the American news media thank you for
being with us on immigration for three
hours
later today he will be meeting with
Israel's Prime Minister tomorrow the
House and Senate will be in session this
week we thank for joining us on this
Sunday enjoy the rest of your weekend